hey man i'm kevin smith and we're going
to do a quick scene study
from clerks man and it's the truly's gum
scene
julie's gum rep played by scott shiafa
one of the first people
i cast in clerks man when we found him
at the first avenue playhouse
auditions and stuff so uh i don't i
still
to this day like i think the origins of
this scene
lie in me being a
like virulent anti-smoker back then
didn't smoke cigarettes hated people
that did and stuff
so the whole thing kind of plays like an
anti-smoking ad
um oddly enough when i wrote the script
i was not a smoker yet a cigarette
smoker
when we shot clerks i had become a
cigarette smoker but i'd just become a
cigarette smoker and you could tell that
because if you look at silent bob when
he smokes and clerks
clearly he doesn't know how to smoke
cigarettes because kevin smith didn't
know how to smoke cigarettes
so uh this scene i think kind of came
from that
from the idea that i was like [ __ ]
smokers man i can't say that and then
you turn it into a joke where the guy's
a scam artist for truly's gum
one day like we live in the world now
like where movies exists right you can
go to a movies pop-up and stuff
one day i'm gonna make sure that we make
chili's gum
because chili's gum is the gum on the
shoe of my entire career
that happens first in clerks and then
[ __ ] the rest happens that was the
doorway
to the rest of my future and stuff so
scott shiafa plays this fantastically
so does brian o'halleran of course as
dante um
all the towns folks are people that i
knew locally including
carl roth who's a guy i went to school
with and stuff um
you know there it's uh it's the angry
mob
such as it was was very small but
effective enough
and and just weird enough for like as
the movie began if you're settling into
clerks you're like what the [ __ ] this is
unreal is a little bit surreal what's
going on
so uh enjoy uh the
truly's gum rep scene do you mind if i
drink this here
sure are you open yep
pack cigarette are you sure am i sure
are you sure not sure about what do you
really want to buy those cigarettes
are you serious how long you've been
smoking what is this a pull how long
you've been a smoker
i don't know since i was about 13. 13.
let's say you're about 19 20 am i right
what in the hell is that that's your
lung
by this time your lung looks like this
you've got to be [ __ ] me you think
i'm [ __ ] you
here what's this it's a trach ring
it's what they install in your throat
when throat cancer takes your voice box
this one came out of a 60 year old man
she smoked until the day he died used to
put the cigarette in this thing and
smoke it that way
excuse me but this is where you're
heading cruddy lung
smoking through a hole in your throat do
you really want that well if it's
already too late i guess we'll just
it's never too late put the cigarettes
back and try some gum instead
here chuli's gum try this it's not the
same
it's cheaper than cigarettes and it
certainly beats this
oh jesus it's a picture of a
cancer-ridden lung
keep it i'll just take the gum
55. you made a very wise choice keep up
the good work
if you're gonna drink that coffee i
think you ought to take it outside
no i think i'll drink it in here thanks
well if you're gonna drink it in here
uh i'd appreciate it if you don't bother
to customers okay
i'm sorry about that
pack of cigarettes what's that this
how long you've been smoking you're
spending what
20 maybe 30 a week on your cigarettes
40 53 53
a week on cigarettes come on would you
give somebody that much money each week
to kill you
because that's what you're doing now by
paying for this so-called privilege to
smoke
hey man i got a crow sometime it's that
kind of mentality
that allows the cancer producing
industry to thrive of course we're all
going to die someday
but do we have to pay for it do we have
to actually throw
hard-earned dollars down on the counter
and say please mr merchant of debt sir
please
tell me something that'll stink up my
breath and my clothes
and fry my lungs now wait a second yeah
yeah now here comes the speech
about how he's just doing his job by
following orders
friends let me tell you about another
group of hate mongers that were just
following orders
they were called nazis that's right
making nazis yeah and they practically
wiped an entire nation of people off the
earth just like your cigarettes are
doing now
i think you gotta leave now you want me
to leave
why because somebody's telling it like
it is somebody's giving these fine
people a wake-up call
no you're loitering and causing a
disturbance i'm a disturbance
you're the disturbance pal you know here
now i am a customer i'm gonna buy some
julie's gum
all right i'm a customer engaged in a
discussion with the other customers
that's right yeah see he's scared now
because he sees the threat we present he
smells the change is coming you can
smell it
you definitely are the source in this
area and we're going to shut you down
for good
for good cancer immersion
[Music]
who's deleting this mob
that guy freeze
let's see some credentials slowly
you're a truly scum representative truly
and you're stirring up all this
anti-smoking sentiment
do what sell more gum get out of here
and you people don't you have jobs to go
to get out of here go commute
you ought to be ashamed of yourselves a
bunch of easily lit automatons try
thinking for yourselves before your
pelton innocent man with cigarettes
uh a pack of cigarettes
hey kids did you like that all these
movies are available on itunes or
netflix in some places
amazon and other places you can find
them they're available
patronize them if you will uh also if
you like this kind of stuff
come on over to that kevin smith club go
to thatkevinsmithclub.com
join up man i do wake and bake three
times a week where i wake up just smoke
weed with you all and stuff come to that
kevin smith club for more
video antics with kevin smith